we love seeing will crow perform better
now he's a rookie so he's learning along
the way he won his first major league
game against the st louis cardinals in
june and the pirates have won three of
his last four starts carlson 02 count
nice start
off speed chase downstairs to
just three pitches so it's a one-hour
walk to goldie nolan aronado against the
pirates this year 306 average and eight
extra base hits and a swing and a ball
bouncing toward the bag at second castro
tags it for one and relay to a double
play well they get the double play
someone asked for it and they got it
season numbers for adam wainwright who
has not lost to the pirates since april
3rd of 2016. since then 7-0
15 starts against pittsburgh the
cardinals have won 12 of the 15. be
ready to hit and hoy park was yesterday
hit his first big league home run
his strength three called belt high and
park didn't like the call wainwright
strikes out his first batter when you've
been doing it as long as adam sometimes
you get those calls to keep brian hayes
outside corner that'll go wayne o's way
back-to-back case i'll tell you what if
he gets the strike zone today look out
yep
and he's not going to be around very
long if that's the case
by the way yadier molina
with the first out recorded and now
number two passes gary carter fifth
place all time in innings caught 17
369 and a third innings holla moran will
lead off swinging a comebacker off of
wainwright's glove deadening the ball
into the infield grass and moran beats
it out
that's an infield hit rodolfo castro
there's a ground ball and that's a
double play the turn by edmond
six four three and gregory polanco comes
up with nobody on base
there's a shot on the ground against the
shift the young gets to it on the first
base side of second the shift works as
pauly d throws out polanco you talked
about tempo with crow he is working fast
tonight
shallow center
and he's there to make the catch no
surprise i hadn't played really well a
little bit of a lean thinking okay might
have to dive nope he's he's ready to die
adam wainwright the cardinals pitcher
swinging a bounding ball to third
fielded up the line by hayes strong
throw across for the out and the inning
is through so crow faces the minimum
hitless and scoreless through his first
three innings top of the lineup here for
will crow to deal with and a swing and a
miss he struck him out for the second
time tonight fastball above the zone one
out paul goldschmidt walked his first
time up lines it out to left drops in
for a base hit cardinals have their
first hit coming with one out here in
the fourth second walk issued by crow
cardinals have something going now
runners at first and second and only one
out tyler o'neill at the plate
a big punch out there for crow who will
face molina now got all neal twice
tonight now real high off speed pitch
breaking ballin
so two outs and two on yachty with two
outs and runners in scoring position a 3
41 hitter this year
molina base head into left
here comes goldie
the throw to the plate is cut off
goldschmidt will score
in a rundown and it's one nothing st
louis as they take the lead one to
nothing yadier molina comes through
a base hit to left
rbi number 46
one-nothing cardinals so we head to the
top of the lineup
swinging a miss and a tardy swing there
by park and strikeout number four for
adam wainwright yeah the backdoor cutter
right here it's almost that's almost in
between a slider and a cutter here's
brian reynolds
inside corner and he struck him out
strikeout number five two in the inning
for wainwright vader de young and edmund
six seven and eight will come up and a
swing of the liner to left offer got a
good jump dives and makes the catch
anthony alford with a tremendous catch
in left field that was extraordinary wow
well it started with his jump and it
finished with a great dive we're talking
about full extension i thought there was
no shot offer would even get there
wow that's a
a double saver and with two outs runner
at first it'll be adam wainwright who
ground it out to third the 2-2
and wainwright hits a fly ball out to
deep left
and it's over alford
that is the worst luck ever ever hate
that double ever painful oh i hate that
rule his second hit this year a ground
rule double and it's the eighth career
double against pittsburgh for wayne oh
it's the first extra base hit for adam
wainwrights in september of 2019
3-2
and he walked him bases loaded his third
walk tonight here comes shelton he's
going to make the move crow will not get
out of the fifth inning they'll bring in
nick mears and they're all loaded up he
is walked in he is single to left three
one for mirrors and a swing and a ground
ball towards second castro up with it
and on to first for the final out so
nick meers comes on and strands
the three inherited runners on base for
the second time to go along with the
walk the yandere molinic
and molina
with a fly ball into deep center
that is over reynolds head
[Applause]
to third
it'll be a double for yachty
and finally he has that double and
that's
396 for his career that ties gabby
hartnett fifth all-time among primary
catchers in history two outs two on the
cardinals need a two out hit from the
young who's had two very fine at bats
tonight
line drive base head into right center
on an o2
de young his second hit of the night
brings in two and it's three to nothing
cardinals and all three runs have scored
tonight after two outs on an 02 pitch
paul deyoung comes through they're gonna
walk tommy edmond wayne wright will hit
and he has doubled tonight
up the middle base head
[Applause]
the throw to the plate the young is safe
at the plate adam wainwright is second
hit tonight
this one brings in the young and it's
four nothing cardinals
how about this
so it's the 255th
time adam wainwright has gone
six or more innings in a start the
cardinals are 178 and 76 when he does
that
and a ground ball more weak contact
tommy edmond adam wainwright with a
seven pitch inning adam wainwright
certainly the story again seven or more
for the fifth straight game for adam
last time he did that was
in 2014 let's strike out number seven
for adam wainwright now 11 in a row the
1-0 pitch
lined into center bader diving catch
harrison banner in center oh what a play
and tonight adam wainwright will try to
finish off what would be his 27th
complete game of his career the first
pitch bottom of the ninth swung on and
hit out to center vader back with rome
and makes the catch another fine play by
harrison bader one out in the bottom of
the ninth the one-two pitch to newman
the fly ball
left field
again
diving forward
harrison bader is putting on a show
tonight
the diving catch to end the eighth
catch near the wall to start this inning
and another diving play
ground ball off the glove a wayno
he does it
88 pitches
he is 18 days away from his 40th
birthday and tonight he gets his 27th
complete game his 11th complete game
shutout only two hits allowed adam
wainwright for nothing the final and he
was absolutely magnificent
you